today we're going to be speaking with
Nicole Purlie, Roth, who's an award
winning cybersecurity journalist for The New York
Times and also author of This Is How They Tell
Me The World Ends the Cyber Weapons Arms Race.
It's so great to have you on. I appreciate it.
Thanks so much for having me, David.
So let's just start kind of at the top level.
I think a lot of people who are
aware of a cyber threat and about the
priority that this has become for so many
governments may not really understand what
a cyber attack might actually mean sort of for the
average person. You might have a vague idea about
could you shut down a water system, for example,
or paralyze an electricity grid or something like
that? What do we mean by cyber attack? What
are the types of things that could be done?
So for a long time, people's real experience
with cyber attacks was really just the theft
of their personal data or maybe their credit
card information, and there was no real
repercussions there. You know, you might have to
deal with identity theft if it got really gnarly.
But for the most part, your bank would probably
pay you back if any money was stolen from your
account or credit card information, that
kind of thing. The problem is that these
days we have rolled so much software into our
critical infrastructure, like the power grid,
like our nuclear plants, like our water treatment
facilities and wastewater treatment plants,
that all of that those access points can be
the target for a cyber attack. And in fact,
we are seeing every year more nation
state hackers, but also low level
cyber criminals target these systems.
And so the attack that we really fear
would be an attack that took out power and
potentially contaminated the water. And actually,
it would look a lot like what we just witnessed in
Texas a few weeks ago when the power went out, the
water supply was contaminated. And in the event of
a cyber attack, which you could use cyber means to
take out the power and contaminate the water. And
we've seen Russia do that in Ukraine and we just
saw attempt to contaminate the water supply in a
small town in Florida the other week. Fortunately,
it was caught. But the problem is with the
cyber attack, there's also the possibility
that hackers could keep those systems down. And
when we've run studies here in the United States
to see how resilient our critical infrastructure
is to cyber attack, some of those simulations
have showed that it could be years before people
were able to bring those systems back online. So
I think we're a little bit better than we were
when those simulations were done. But there's
a real threat of a cyber attack on on the grid.
So when it comes to the kind of identity theft,
credit card theft stuff that many of us have
dealt with, all of a sudden I had a period where,
like Uber and Dauda, charges were showing up on my
credit card and the annoyance type stuff, it seems
the motivation of the individual is basically to
get free stuff, to get a free, free takeout or a
free Uber ride or whatever the case may be. When
we start talking about things like shutting down a
power grid, contaminating water, et cetera, it's
correct me if I'm wrong. It seems we're talking
about a fork that is more malicious for the sake
of being malicious, of making a political point,
of of making an attack that may be more against
an institution or a country or an organization.
Are those these two forks in terms of
motivations or is it more complicated than that?
Well, I think you're right. I mean, a lot of the
attacks we have seen on critical infrastructure
has been messaging. When Russia shut off the
power in Ukraine, first in 2015 and then in 2016,
they only did it for a few hours. And I
really believe that that was to send a message
to sort of see doubt. And Ukrainians mind that
their new government had things under control.
It was really political messaging and sort of
hanging this threat over the population that
Russia could turn off the power at the flip
of a switch. Other attacks have had different
motivations. We caught Iran rifling around
the controls at a dam and the United States,
fortunately, it was the wrong dam. We have to
bowmen dams. One of them holds back us dunamis
worth of water and organ, and the other holds back
a babbling brook in New York. And they got into
the one that holds back a babbling brook and it
was under repair. So it wasn't an actual threat.
But, you know, who knows what the message was
there? I think it was probably just some sort
of experimentation to see if they could get into
the systems in case they needed to one day unleash
the locks at that dam. And that's more of what
we're starting to see. We're starting to see
nation state hackers get into these
critical infrastructure systems,
not necessarily because they
want to do something immediately,
but because we're all planning for some kind of
geopolitical trigger where we might need to be in
a position to turn off the lights or unleash the
locks at a dam or contaminate the water supply.
But each of these attacks essentially enshrines
critical infrastructure as a legitimate target for
a cyber attack. And at the end of the day, it's
civilian populations who would suffer the result
of those attacks. So it's, yeah, more dangerous.
So this is one of my questions about how this fits
into warfare more broadly, because, you know, one
of the things that's happened over the last 10 to
15 years is we've heard more about and it actually
has moved in the direction of the idea of a.
That's like a boots on the ground war, the likes
of which, you know, certainly the first Gulf War,
to a degree, the 2003 Iraq War, things are moving
away from that. Drone warfare is certainly part of
it, but also so is cyber warfare. But a foreign
power, for example, shutting off electricity in
a large part of the United States. We understand
the chaos that it will create. We understand the
damage it can do. But how would it fit into a
broader war in the sense of what would it be
part of trying to accomplish for the foreign power
that does it? I'm guessing it's not shut the power
off so they can steal Florida from us and make
it part of some other country. There must be
what would be the goal or how would it fit in?
Yeah, it's a really good question and it's an
important question because you don't want to
overhype the threat. Right. But it is the reality
that Russia has been targeting our grid
for several years now. A few years ago,
the Department of Homeland Security published a
screenshot that literally showed Russian hackers
inside our power plants with their fingers on
the switches that could turn off the lights.
So we know that they have gotten into
these systems, which begs the question,
what are they doing there? At what point will
they see some kind of incentive or motivation
to turn off the lights? I do think that this is
all battlefield preparation for some future event,
whether it's a declaration of war. And this would
be one element of that warfare turning off the
lights or shutting off the communication systems
in the event that geopolitical tensions got so
heated that one of these countries felt
the need to do so. We have been hacking
into Russia. It's great. I broke that story with
my colleague David Sanger a couple of years ago,
partly as retaliation somewhat for the
election, but also for Russia's acts
and incursions of our own grid. But we've been
doing it more as mutually assured destruction.
I was going to say, yeah, I was going to say
it reminds me of like during nuclear weapon
development, a lot of people say, what is the
circumstance where we would ever use even ten
of these nukes? Like, what is that situation? And
it becomes this conversation of, well, you know,
if they did it, we would we would need to be in a
position to do it. And being in a position to do
it would disincentives them from doing it.
It it has a sort of similar feel,
as you mentioned, that, yes, it is our attempt at
mutually assured destruction in the digital age.
The problem is that nuclear analogies really don't
fit so neatly in cyber. For one, this is all code,
right, where we're attacking these systems
with code. There's a low barrier to entry.
You know, if we have a system, it is entirely
possible for that attack to be discovered,
for those methods to be discovered, for that
code to be picked up and reverse engineered
and retrofitted and used back on us. And in cyber,
what we've noticed over the last 10 years is that
people learn a lot from their adversary. You
know, we pulled off an attack with Israel on
Iran's nuclear plant where we broke into their
nuclear facility and Anton's nuclear facility.
We dispatched code that jumped from
their Microsoft Windows systems into
their industrial controllers. And we eventually
use that code to spin their uranium centrifuges
out of control or slow them down. And
we ultimately destroyed a thousand of
their centrifuges. No one has pulled off a cyber
attack, that level of sophistication since. But,
you know, what our adversaries have learned
is they don't need to have the sophistication
of that attack to do damage. A couple of years
after that attack, we saw Iran hit Saudi Aramco,
world's largest oil company, Saudi Arabia, with an
attack that just used rudimentary code to wipe out
the data on their systems and replace it with an
image of a burning American flag. And so we're all
sort of learning after each other and each attack
has sort of build off the capabilities of the
last. And unlike nuclear, where you need fissile
material to drop a bomb, right. In cyber, you
just need a laptop and someone with the skills.
And increasingly you can purchase those skills
and code and capabilities off a gray market. So
it's really unregulated space. It is getting more
and more dangerous, particularly as we digitize
more of our infrastructure. And the thing I think
people don't realize is that America might still
be the greatest offensive player in this realm.
Like I said, no one has pulled off anything close
to the attack. We pulled off on Iran more than 10
years ago. But we are also the. Most targeted, we
have more nation states and cyber criminals lined
up at our borders, at our systems, knocking on the
door, getting in and a lot of cases and planting
back doors and where the most vulnerable in a lot
of cases because we are so wired much more so than
adversaries like North Korea and Iran, et cetera.
So on that note, I mean, in the limited time we
have left, the reaction of some might be, well,
we've got to pull all of our we have to go
backwards technologically. We have to get a lot of
stuff that's currently networked off of networks,
a silo, things, et cetera. In in most instances,
that's that's not really a solution to problems.
Would it be the wrong the wrong reaction to this?
No. I mean, I think we do need to step back and
think harder about the defense of these systems.
80 percent of America's critical infrastructure
is owned and maintained by private companies.
And any attempt to sort of legislate that they
have better security has has always failed.
Lobbyists have always watered it down. So any
attempt to secure our critical infrastructure
has come in the form of an executive order,
first under Obama and then there was one under
Trump. But really, you know, these are all just
setting voluntary standards for these critical
infrastructure owners to up their security. And
unfortunately, a lot of these systems are
owned by small, medium sized businesses,
local municipal systems that simply don't have
the security budgets or resources of a PG&E say
here in California. So they have to rely on this
outside network of contractors and supervisors.
And the fact that they have to let those people
in remotely creates an opportunity for hackers.
So what do we do if we're not going to legislate
that these companies have to up their security?
What do you do? And I think one of the things
that we need to start talking about is creating
better market incentives for these companies to up
their security, you know, giving tax credits maybe
to companies who used to factor authentication
and have all of their software up to date and
passed with flying colors on a penetration testing
exam. Or perhaps it's time to exact penalties
on companies who are not updating and patching
their systems and allowing anyone to remote. And
so I do actually think it's a really
important question to ask ourselves, OK,
if we're not going to let the government into
these private systems, if we're going to rely
on the market, well, the market has always led
us down a path of further vulnerability because
security has no return. Return on investment.
Yeah, it's the Deepwater Horizon,
the five hundred thousand dollar value that
if you install it everywhere you protect,
but it's unlikely you'll need it everywhere
and then they install it nowhere at all.
That's such a great analogy. I hadn't thought
of that, but that is the perfect analogy. And
so we really need to have these conversations
around how to lock up these systems. And,
you know, there's been some conversations about
should we have a digital Geneva Convention?
Should we set some kind of international norms
of behavior where we would agree not to hack
Russia's power grid and they would agree
not to have cars or hospitals or elections?
The problem is we, the United States, will
never agree to those norms because, one,
we are still we we still have a huge offensive
advantage. But also, too, we don't trust that
our adversaries would hold to those agreements
because they outsource many of their attacks
to cyber criminals, to contractors and
front companies. The attacks that we conduct
out of the United States come out of the Pentagon,
Cyber Command or maybe the NSA, if it's espionage
or the other intelligence agencies. We don't rely
on some, you know, security engineer at Google and
tap them on the shoulder at night and say tonight
you're working with us. We just don't have that
ability or plausible deniability. So we worry that
if we ever agree to these norms, that these other
countries would just sort of say, well, we won't
do it, but they would outsource those attacks.
Right. We don't we don't really want to commit not
to doing it. And we wouldn't believe that their
commitment would be it would be trustworthy. They
may believe the exact same about this as well. And
it makes it a very complicated situation. We've
been speaking with Nicole Pearl Roth, who is a
cybersecurity journalist for The New York Times.
The book is This Is How They Tell Me The
World Ends the Cyber Weapons Arms Race.
Nicole, really appreciate your time today.
Thank you so much for having me. The
David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.